bajo un solo coro una caravana de
migrantes venezolanos marchó por Ciudad
Juárez en el norte de México intentaban
cruzar el río Bravo para llegar a
Estados Unidos pero la patrulla
fronteriza respondió con balas de goma
nos han atacado nos han agredido y ya
pues uno como en defensa se queda parado
gritando y ya no disparan ya no tenemos
armas estamos desarmados y nos aplastan
con su fuerza y es que las puertas no
estuvieron abiertas para los migrantes
en un año en el que el tránsito cambió
por primera vez llegaron a la frontera
norte mexicana más venezolanos cubanos y
nicaragüenses que migrantes del Salvador
Guatemala y Honduras
lo que no cambió fue la movilización en
masa en este año las caravanas volvieron
a cruzar Centroamérica rumbo al norte
por motivos que siguen siendo los mismos
porque
Venezuela está dura la situación país
está dura no se puede prácticamente
vivir y en un futuro a sus hijos a
nuestros hijos durante el año fiscal
2022 los agentes fronterizos de Estados
Unidos interceptaron a casi 2,4 millones
de personas y se rompieron algunos
registros según datos oficiales en los
últimos 12 meses más de 850 migrantes
murieron al intentar llegar a Estados
Unidos lo que convierte al 2022 en el
más mortífero y en uno en el que Estados
Unidos refuerza sus fronteras con
medidas que incluyen a terceros países
para controlar el tránsito